[Music]
this is star talk we've got another
cosmic queries edition for you and all
purpose general astrophysics cosmic
queries and we've got an old friend of
star talk he's been on once or twice
before uh hakeem alusei did i pronounce
that right hakeem close close yeah yeah
it's a it's a oh and a sh
olu
think oh shady
it's great to have you back on and i got
as my guest co-host paul mercurio paul
good to see you man good to see you
again hakeem great to meet you and good
to meet you great to be back
yeah yeah it's been too long paul and
and and you're a host of the inside out
podcast yes so and i was once a guest on
that program you were and we got to get
you back on it's been a while you were
great okay all right excellent there's a
lot of sobbing during the interview but
uh we cut that out and um
so so akeem you're you're you're a
fellow astrophysicist um educated at
stanford and you're right now a
professor at george mason university
yeah and and you've been a busy guy
you've got a memoir came out a couple of
years ago when did that come out
this past june well that recently yeah
june 2021 yeah yeah because your story
you're in the military you were
uh weren't you homeless for a while or
something yeah in the streets absolutely
yeah yeah i had a couple of abouts with
homelessness um
not really sleeping on the street
homeless sleeping on somebody's couch on
somebody's floor homeless
right you know those two different
levels right there's different levels
that's right yeah yeah
so but anyway grant all that has worked
out and yeah i encourage people to read
that memo or memoirs i think as a genre
are packed with all the lessons anyone
ever needs in life absolutely and so i'm
delighted to have yours as part of that
part of that
community of storytelling uh to help
people bring shape to their lives so
paul collected uh questions from our
patreon supporters and this is
all-purpose grab bag astrophysics it is
so i know a little bit you know probably
more so we'll we'll knock this out we'll
see okay
but just before we begin what was the
title of your thesis your phd thesis oh
yeah my phd thesis was titled
development of a global model of the
sun's atmosphere with an emphasis on the
solar transition region that is so weird
because mine was exactly the same thing
two of us it's like
it's like we're brothers from another
mother what come on okay so so we we
need sun expertise right oh absolutely
the sun seems to always be misbehaving
that it burps up gases it it's it
unleashes solar flares
it's got spots
and what have you been doing to the sun
yeah so you know i look at how energy
and mass are transferred uh throughout
the solar atmosphere so traditionally
the way we look at it is you know by the
mid 20th century we thought we
understood stars really well but it
failed at the surface of the star
because if you look at the surface of a
star you see all these plasma loops and
jets and you know weird stuff happening
right that's due to actual magnetic
fields so um you know i'll tell you what
really was cool for me
now
this
you know paul you're going to probably
have thought the same thought but to me
because he had the same thesis he was
studying the same subject yeah but you
know what we do as astronomers and
astrophysicists is that we look at light
and we say oh here's what the matter
millions of miles away are doing and the
fields are doing based on our analysis
of this light so i really got into
you know the interaction of light and
matter so i i left graduate school and
went to silicon valley and my first
patents were on using spectroscopy in
semiconductor manufacturing
so paul what were your first patents on
i invented this thing called sunglasses
mr wiseguy okay so there which everyone
gets to look at the sun what about solar
slight can we i just have a question
about solar cycle right was that still a
conundrum and not sort of something that
we have our head around yet
yeah so we say solar cycle what we're
talking about for those people who might
not know is you know just like planets
are like a bar magnet a planet like the
earth that's spinning fast and have a
liquid iron core so is the sun uh but
the difference is the sun doesn't have a
solid surface it's plasma and so you
know when it gets fully separated one
pole at the top the opposite pole at the
bottom they then migrate and mix up and
when they're mostly mixed is when we get
the biggest flares and coronal mass
ejections and then they pass by and it
flips right and it just does that over
and over that's an 11 year cycle right
yep that's 11 year cycle or 22 if you go
back to the original configuration right
yeah and so the thing is is that this
so-called source of these magnetic
fields we call the solar dynamo and
people who do helioseismology
have somehow
i don't know the details you know if you
look at the interior structure of the
sun there's the core where the fusion
reactions occur then there's this this
region known as a radiative zone where
the energy moves out via light then
there's the outer 30 percent that's like
boiling we call it the convective zone
so the magnetic fields appear to be
generated at the boundary between the
convective and the radiative zone
exactly how
who knows
i don't know maybe someone does and if
you can answer that then you can explain
the solar cycle and sort of what was
behind oh yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly
well part of it is that the sun does not
rotate as one
physical solid object right it's that
the equator rotates
faster than other latitudes right that's
right that's right so you know it it so
it's really weird you know and it also
has if you look at jupiter's bandit
structure it also has a banded structure
in the subsurface that the
helioseismologists have figured out and
uh you know and these bands go at
different velocities right
so you know you have this big you know
difference like you say it's slow at the
poles faster at the at the equator but
then you know there's details within
there right and it's the equal same
speed at each pole that is i have no
idea if that's the case or not okay
can you get back to me on that because i
uh yeah i'll go i'll go no no we have a
mission going to the sun but the sun's
very hot so we're going to go at night
and then
with a glass of water
all right so paul give me some questions
yeah we've got a lot of great questions
we have a lot of great questions today
so we're going to start with kevin bond
we know that the big bang theory created
the universe and it's been constantly
expanding then it begins to shrink and
implode on itself so when the universe
reaches that final point of imploding to
the smallest point
is that event what recreates a big bang
theory and recreates the universe now
there's a second part to this but i
think we should do it in two parts and
that's the first part
i got this guys don't worry about it
i could take this hakeem if you want me
to take this one
there is no
observational evidence ever in the
history of cosmology to say that we're
going to recollapse
none all data has always shown a one-way
trip which has been very unsettling to
people who prefer tidy
stories where
you know it expands and contracts and
expands and contracts and it's like no
it's a one-way trip and it's
philosophically unsettling to me yeah
yeah yeah do we know
it's only a one-way trip scientifically
the explosive energy exceeds the
gravitational energy that would pull it
all back together that's all it is it's
that simple so deal with it
and i'll say i say it off and i'll say
it again the universe is under no
obligation to make sense to us
i think i've seen that on a t-shirt
somewhere exactly i don't know yeah
bumper sticker or
that's the interesting thing about this
big bang thing is because um you know if
you hear
people talk about it in the public
sphere you know there's some sort of
um there's one train of thought that
leaves me to believe
that people think that
every 30 40 50 years all the world
scientists get together in a room and
the topic is what's the big lie we're
all going to agree on
right
that's what they think is happening
right i think it's happening right they
know nobody can agree on anything
so just reading a book written by albert
einstein or somewhere else someone else
in 1938 right and so he was it's called
the evolution of physics and one of the
things he was talking about is how
physical thought
uh you know what we call the scientific
method develop and so you know in the
western world i know the other author
it's leopold enfield right that's right
that's right yep that's correct and so
the thing that he picked up on that i
was unaware of so you know one thing i
knew that you know my fellow western
scientists typically don't know is ibn
al haitham you know the guy who wrote
the book of optics and and uh you know
sort of like you know the golden age of
islam very important age of islam around
the year 10 21 right so i was like why
weren't we celebrating a thousand years
of the scientific method in 2021 because
he wrote the book of optics in 1021 but
he insisted that what we believe to be
true about the universe should be
consistent with what we observe to be
true about the universe and the thing
that einstein points out is that what we
observe can only take us so far because
the universe is deceptive and it throws
you these clues that can lead you astray
and so like aristotle at al they took
all the clues in and they came up with a
model that was wrong but was consistent
with what they observed that galileo
decided to do these mental experiments
that you could never actually do in real
life right he's like you know he was
noticing that if i roll a ball down one
plane it goes almost to the same height
up the next plane but then
if you you know make the the second
plane have a shallower angle it still
tries to reach the same height now he
imagined what if i got rid of all the
friction on the between the the ball and
the floor and i got rid of the friction
within the wheels it would go forever is
what he realized right and that's what
overturned everything was him imagining
an experiment that we could never do now
here's the thing about that you can take
that idea and you can make predictions
and i feel like the big bang is the best
example of how powerful that technique
is because unlike other experimental
science where you can like control
variables you
if this happened what must have occurred
and then go look for it and the fact
that we have all these crazy predictions
that have all you know
the high precision have come to fruition
so i i get on that because the good
doctor said
observations
right
everything we observe shows that the
universe is not going to collapse but
the big bang has gone even further it's
not just what we observe is what we
could have imagined must have occurred
and then we find that it's there with
high precision so it's not like one idea
in competition with others like the
whole idea of the universe being small
and dense and hot and expanding at this
point is observe fat
yeah i i would i would add to that in a
more simple terrestrial example if
there's a cave and it just snowed and
you see bare
prince in the snow entering the cave
without ever having seen the bear
you have evidence that there was a bear
in the cage
absolutely there are ways to know
without actually seeing
right
but but but is there some sort of is it
is there some hesitation to sort of
theorize on thing you know i mean
obviously not i mean that's what science
is about it's not just observation but
it's about going the next step i mean
like the fact that the the earth the the
big bang it's 13.86 billion but the
there's a star out there that's 14 15 16
yeah that's right so if you remember
that one
they'll pop up they'll pop up every now
and then you know and so yes it's a
conundrum and so that's i mean that's
the fun part about being on the frontier
the frontier is full of conundrums only
some of them get the interest of the
press and the public but what they want
to think is that see scientists have no
clue about anything and their other no
we keep working on it and we figure it
out that's all yeah yeah you know an
example i like to give is you know it's
not new to me i mean i didn't invent it
but it's the damselfly it lives but a
day in a forest right now imagine you're
a damselfly scientist and you're in a
forest and you see a tree standing you
see a rotting log and you see a seed on
the ground
you could not think oh wow the seed must
grow into the tree which we felt right
you got to get less than dyes and rots
right right right you got to get lucky
you need many generations you need to
make lots of observations you need
people to say oh
i noticed that when the tree falls it
looks like the oh and i saw the seed
fall right and you can begin to piece
things together but you still have some
gaps okay so we just launched the james
webb space telescope one of those gaps
is from when the big bang radiation was
set free what we call recombination 380
million years ago
all the way up until we have stars and
galaxies right there's a big gap of no
knowledge that the the the dark ages
reionization the first pl stars and
galaxies you know so
even though you know a lot you don't
necessarily know everything but because
you don't know everything it doesn't
mean you don't know a lot
right love it yeah right that's the
perfect way of putting it exactly
worthy as well
but okay no that's brilliant it's
brilliant if you wanted to say a damn
thing while you were talking it was
brilliant listen if you want to
rationalize your laziness and lack of
knowledge that way good for you go for
it wait a minute wait a minute
how's the one white dude in the
conversation
i'm not sure lazy
all right i got another one we're going
to move on uh
i apologize to the person this is a
tough one to pronounce uh slawik
walzick nice irish boy um hello
wonderful people when will we be able to
create gravitational waves and use them
to send information like we do
with electromagnetic waves now
listen i don't know but i'm pretty sure
when it's possible the uh airlines are
going to keep it from happening because
i've been doing that forever man
like i could like flex my pecs and send
like you know
gravitational waves out and then you
woke up and then what happened
then i started flexing my
trapezius ease
so paul with that question we're going
to take a quick break and when we come
back more cosmic queries with hakeem
dr o dr oh i love it all right we'll be
right back
okay
we're back cosmic query is a grab bag
edition on all things astrophysics so i
got one of my colleagues from a
professor george mason
when i'm up in new york walking through
the streets i hear people yelling yeah
all the time
you just need a cowboy hat when you put
that on you can go yeehaw and it worked
yeah yeah so so paul uh paul just before
we begin you do stand up right i mean
not during covid but you're a stand-up
guy
did we first meet
on
the cold bears late show we first
might have been the daily show i was
writing on that show oh yeah yeah so you
go way back and that's we connected and
i was a fan i know you warm up the crowd
there and yeah
yeah uh well i was right around the show
performed on the show the warm-up and
then i went to the colbert report and
then went to the late show with stephen
colbert and
we've kind of been uh attached at the
hip and that's great it's great to have
that tracking it's great to hear that
yeah we're kind of in the same mindset
like there's sort of a core group of us
that started at the daily show that
started that kind of point of view and
stephen came in a few years after we
started the show
and you know obviously he was great on
the show and then that led to his own
show so we kind of have a shorthand know
how we like to parse the news and all of
that when we first started on the daily
show we weren't doing just politics in
the media's coverage of politics we were
doing everything music pop culture and
when john came on board like three years
in
john stewart he focused the show a
little pretty much on you know that's
right people forget that the daily show
long pre-dates jon stewart yeah it was
three over three years with craig
kilbourne
yeah right
and uh very lovely locks of golden hair
that he had and uh and he was great
because he would read anything he didn't
care about offending anybody or whatever
and he had that very dry doug herzog was
the president comedy central who was
involved in creating the show really
liked
uh craig from sportscenter and that's
how he got to know and so he kind of
yeah so anyway yeah let me run my idea
about you paul i call it the monthly
show okay
what we do
listen uh
i think we're gonna it might be a little
dated that's all i'm saying
it might be it might be i have a yearly
show i want to do and
so so paul what was the what question
did you leave off with it
when will we be able to create
gravitational waves and use them to send
information like we do with
electromagnetic waves now
so let me let me start that out and i'll
go hand off to hakeem gravitational
waves travel the same speed as
electromagnetic waves so you're not
gaining anything by this plus they're
very hard to make they take a lot of
energy more so than
you know turning on your laser so i i
don't know hakeem can you do you think
of any advantages to using gravitational
waves uh yeah encrypted communications
in a way right
it's like you know i'm going to take my
look two little pulsars binary pulsars
and i'm going to move them in this way
to create a series of uh
you know x's and o so it's secret
messages oh
yeah yeah
and the other thing is that
so so i hadn't considered that of course
gravitational waves pass through
everything if you if you if you
participate in the space-time continuum
gravity waves will
go right on through it they don't even
care so what you're telling me is you're
going to send me some secret message
with orbiting pulsars and then i decode
it on the other side and no one can
block it right no one can do anything
unless they know you know the ferengi or
the klingons or you know the org or
trying to intercept we got uh-oh oh we
have a geek in the house
why is this not
is this is this being experimented with
it all or is it just too paul he used to
work in the navy so he can't hold any
further information he'd have to kill me
if he tells me i don't want to die right
now well i could bring you into the lab
forever to entertain uh
you know
so so is it it's not is it conceivable
that this could be developed for that
kind of use well the key thing is what
uh the good doctor said and then you
notice he talked about the amount of
energy required and you notice that i
invoked pulsars you know neutron stars
right so that yeah yeah doing it making
them happen is so the other question i
have is
you know that's detectable gravitational
waves i don't know it to be the case but
i would imagine that moving any mass
will create some sort of you know
gravitational ripple just like great you
just have to accelerate them that's all
so it's not it's not movement somewhere
accelerating yeah and that creates the
right
yeah so it's a matter of uh you know how
sensitive can you detect and to signal
the noise back you know
for your system right so what you what
you're suggesting implying is that ligo
laser interferometry gravitational wave
observatory which is our first means of
detecting
colliding black holes
though that cost a zillion dollars and a
grant from the national science
foundation and mon you know monies from
congress that's just our first
foray yeah that's true in 100 years
maybe we get way more that's like
galileo in his first test
and wait a little while and we'll we'll
be knocking this out
and i i can
so i can catch you walking down the
street just wiggling your arms in a
particular way uh yeah so paul what
what's what's next up what do you think
is the best wait who's asking the
question paul i want to know who
i got to step up here that's three
questions from dudes i'm stepping in for
the women
i need a question from a woman all right
okay we'll get you on the next one here
we
okay uh go do you think is the best
strategy to expand broadband internet
access to rural areas i've seen lots of
talk about satellite high altitude tech
but also the concept of using unused tv
frequencies uh between the active ones
in the vhf and uhf which seems far more
practical i think this is important
especially in a pandemic to achieve
anything close to equity and education
and i couldn't agree more i've said it
once i've said it a thousand times rural
kansas needs squid game
and uh okay let's get on that will ya
so what is the what is the viability of
this it's not just rural kansas there
are a lot of very uh desolate parts of
china um siberia and people you know
live there in alaska
so you got any ideas i can't i'm
thinking i don't i mean isn't that what
elon is trying to do is you know every
time he launches there's a hundred
satellites that get deployed and that's
you know that's why it's fraught with
danger to comment on the topic but uh
you know there's a starling satellites
right he's attempting to do that but i
think he's not the only game in town i
cannot say what the best uh
option is but i think we all agree that
um
you know there's an injustice
in it not being uh available to everyone
and you know it's going to further you
know
you know one thing i think about is is
how
if you look throughout history i love to
study human history over you know in the
universe's history
dirt poor
versus you know well-off you know you
look at these um
old movies right today the average
person lives better than a king or queen
in ancient times just because we have
air conditioning completely clear water
right clean water
but
you know plus plus we can all we can all
buy and eat a turkey leg
there is that there is that we can't
that's the evidence
and there's court jesters there's court
jesters like myself that are everywhere
now see we got paul jesus minus the hat
that's what he is with the hat and then
i do a little thing and you know healthy
and comfy jesters is what we have in in
the modern world but but but the thing
is dirt poor is still dirt poor right
dirt poor the mediterranean excuse me in
the
medieval times dirt poor today they're
still pretty darn dirt poor and uh
you know the the top keeps moving
further and further away right and so
when you move the bulk of humanity
like we are the knowledge animal right
we're the technology knowledge animal so
what you're doing is you're giving a
percentage of humanity access to all of
humanity's knowledge and another group
of people are just like uh
y'all go fetch some water you know i
mean it you know it's terrible but this
feels like something sort of going back
to what neil was saying a minute ago
sort of you know so why doesn't science
know everything
but is this is this sounds
conspiratorial but is it these large
carriers have the ability and are sort
of holding on to the technology for
later like this seems
not that complicated to achieve here's
my read on that well first of all one of
the problems is
the
uh it depends on what you needed the
communication satellites to do if it's
to actually speak to one another
in real time you can't use
geosynchronous satellites for that
because as fast as light moves the time
delay is mostly unacceptable to people
if you want witty repartee in a
conversation if it's streaming then it
doesn't matter you just wait there and
it streams and gathers and it buffers
and then you play it the problem is
orbiting satellites mostly are
equatorial
and so if you are at very high latitudes
or very low latitud you know high
polar latitudes it doesn't have much
satellite coverage and so
um and you always need a satellite over
you in order to be sending you the
signal
so if you have low-lying satellites
they you need more of them for there
always to be a satellite above your head
if they're far away it can be over
everybody's head right
but if they're really low they can only
see a couple hundred miles at a time so
that's what starlink is putting up i i
lost count
i came how many satellites this is
putting up in the orbit yeah same here i
just see a new uh
this number of new satellites went up
right you see these announcements and
then there's isn't there a practical
limit to what how many can be up there
at one time and function and not
crash into each other isn't there that
there's the kessler effect
hakeem you know about the kessler effect
you don't know about the casper effect
the kessler castle run the castle
would you
[Laughter]
so the kessler effect is uh there's a
guy named kessler i think it was when
was it in the 70s uh he did a
calculation he noted that as our
satellite population increases
okay
what would happen if a satellite broke
apart and then destroyed other
satellites and broke them apart oh right
so so suppose two satellites collide
then each one let's say makes 10 pieces
moving at 18 000 miles an hour so then
each of those 10 pieces hits another
satellite breaking them into ten pieces
right so go from one to ten to a hundred
to a thousand destroyed satellites he
cited a threshold of satellite density
in orbit
above which we are at risk of if one
satellite gets damaged they all come out
because it becomes a catastrophic uh
avalanche of destroyed satellites so yes
there is a limit we're not there yet but
by the way they showed that in the movie
gravity
and i saw that sucker in in an imax that
that was the castle the kessler
when it breaks when it hits and breaks
up you mean everything breaks up and it
kept breaking up and and this mass of
satellite debris that's why their
communication links got taken out we
already have a solution for this
because this is how we run our uh
nuclear fusion fission reactors so all
we need is control rods just drop some
control rods in orbit
they'll absorb the pieces
reaction stopped
like giant magnetic poles that just
anything that's metal like just
okay see that's the problem when you're
a scientist and you also have a sense of
humor
you might say something wild and crazy
and somebody take you seriously i don't
know that's because that's because i'm
an idiot
you could sell me a bridge and i would
buy it so i'm i'm an idiot when it comes
to some of this stuff so what but we got
to take a quick break when we come back
we'll have the third and final segment
of our astrophysics grab bag
cosmic queries on star talk
yeah paul uh
we're back star talk cosmic wait wait
can i please show
so i you know i just made a mistake i
made once before and i just wanted to
tell paul the story so i used to teach
i was working in silicon valley in the
daytime and i was teaching astronomy
course that night at foothill community
college in the san francisco bay area
which is an interesting foothill yeah
yeah you know and um our guy andy frack
noy write the textbook all right well
guys there yeah yeah so anyway
uh i like to make jokes and so one of my
jokes is a lot of my jokes are
self-deprecating humor okay and where i
come from in mississippi we often turn
the th that occurs at the end of words
to an f
okay
so breath is breath you know so i would
joke in my classes and say earth
and i'd even write earth on the board
erf right but being i get my first
quizzes back and i see that some of the
students for whom english is a second
language
have written earth on their exams
oh man oh you're just messing with them
oh why you do why you gotta do that i
know i know i got to think why you do
that hakeem uh did they call him into
the administration listen you're making
our students dumber we have i know
you're the only
i self-correct just to get the names out
there the guy we're talking about is
andrew fracknoy who's a big uh astronomy
educator and if you go to the foothills
uh college website you'll see that
there's a silicon valley lecture series
a speaker series there so
this relationship goes way back
so truth would be true right that's
right
truth would be true exactly yeah
love it i do it on purpose yeah how do
how to promote
how to promote illiteracy no listen oh
it's the exact opposite it's the exact
opposite let me tell you my oh here we
go
you know this is from the cosmic queries
so there you go i was reading about you
know linguistics and i was reading about
how the language of intelligentsia went
from you know greek to latin to english
and one of the reasons why
this
whatever i was reading claimed is
because the languages are more and more
efficient and one thing about the
english language that it doesn't have as
many of the like gendered uh you know
stuff
but here's the thing
i also looked at what the linguists
think about what they call black well so
the romance language is almost all nouns
are gendered right so you then you have
to then
structure the sentence to accommodate
the gender of the noun which has nothing
to do with sex it's just that's right in
fact that was the first usage of the
term gendered was was invo in like in
interest
he that did not answer the door like
that kind of thing yeah yeah so so
anyway if you look at what linguistics
think of what they call black vernacular
english or ebonics
which is you know the the the language
of my homeland
then one characteristic it has in
comparison to normal english is it's
more efficient
so
my prediction is that
all the highly educated people gonna be
saying truth and breath and death
because it's so much more efficient
oh my god it's so much more efficient
what's up what's up what's up or it
could be what up like so you're right so
i just saved the second in my day to
focus on something no in fact but you
don't need the what it's just no it's
just paul paul it's just suck that's
right oh my god
all right yeah all right
[Laughter]
i tried to come up with a slang that had
the most number of collapsed syllables
in it okay and i worked with this with
my son and this is what we came up with
right
ready okay
no i'm saying
what is that
i got i was do you know
do you know what i'm saying you know
what i'm saying but you know what you
you brought up another that's efficient
right i know the story you can't beat
that that's impressive that's impressive
no i mean
that sounds that sounds like a question
that would be a final on hakeem's class
that he teaches where he makes people's
dumber like that would be the final
question
you have to take that sentence that neil
just said and make it into the shortest
i love what you just said paul because i
do make people dumber
right now because no i'll tell you why
you're brilliant but that's not the
intent of starting
can we get back to the questions please
hear me out we got hard-working patreon
members okay what did you know and every
patreon member is going to love this did
you notice how often
i have used the phrase i don't know
right to me
the the key thing is knowing the
difference between when you know and
when you don't know and you leave my
classes
understanding that distinction very
rarely do people walk in understanding
it i didn't understand it right i was in
my phd program and then art walker would
say to me do you know that and i'd be
like
yeah cause i just like he's like i guess
not you know that i'm like oh okay i'll
be back yeah so you know that's right
i'm making them dumber i'm making them
know they don't know ah i know you're
brilliant come on you wanna jump to the
next one all right paul yeah go for it
all right i'm leonard uh letty uh good
morning uh uh two-part question why is
the speed of light 186 miles
uh mps and not 190 170 or some other
speed and the second part is if i'm in a
spaceship going point six c and have an
oncoming spaceship at point six e isn't
the other spaceship traveling faster
than that's the speed of light according
to my frame of reference i just want to
say leonard i think it's inappropriate
for you to ask hakeem and neil to help
you with an astrophysics exam question
it's clear right you're taking a test
right now that's what that sounds
exactly
you are cheating later exactly
i don't know but i'm gonna tune in to
star talk and get this answer right on
this test
uh so so there you go and if you want me
to all right so i i'll jump in here so
light travels as a wave
and
waves one of the things that surprised
me about waves when i was learning about
waves as a student is what comes from
where so here's what i mean suppose i
have a long string and i do my hand like
that
right and i send the wave traveling down
right let's say i do it over and over
right now those that wave that's
produced is going to have certain
properties it's going to have an
amplitude it's going to have a
wavelength the distance between the
peaks is going to have a frequency how
many peaks occur in a certain interval
of time
um and the wave is going to move at a
particular speed
and so it turns out that
the frequency of the wave is determined
by how an amplitude determine how how
fast and how much i move my hand right
but the speed of the wave is determined
by the string itself
it is determined by
its its uh
resistance to its change of state of
motion it's it's you know it's it's
material density and it's also released
you know related to how tight it's
strung right it's tension right so one
wants to stop it from moving and other
wants to move it back to equilibrium but
it's just that so the question is if i
see a wave moving like if we talk about
the speed of sound right what we're
talking about is the speed at which
waves move through that medium
okay so if it's a table i knock on my
table that sound wave moves through it
it's a different speed and when i speak
through the air it's a different speed
than when i clap my hands under water
and it's because of not what i'm doing
but the nature of the medium itself so
light is an electromagnetic wave it's
moving through the vacuum of space time
and so
the speed of light is a constant
right so is it set by the medium which
is the vacuum
yeah so as light goes through a medium
it is
stopping and then getting
[Music]
re-re-emitted in the same direction it
came in and so and that pause
effectively slows down the speed of
light in that medium
but between stops it is going the speed
of light but but we don't generally
speak of it in that way we say light
slows down in glass in air in a diamond
as long as it's just transparent
medium for that but yeah so that's good
so what you're saying i came as the
property of the vacuum is such that you
get that speed for that wave but is
there a vacuum in other words you
mentioned the table and sound going
through a table versus in underwater it
is about the environment that you're in
as well right but space time is
different right so if you look at you
know so we do these things in these
weird diagrams called um space-time
diagrams right and so
light is all happens to be the speed of
causality in our universe right nothing
can happen
faster than that speed so you know so
it's one of those things where if you
look at a space-time diagram you see oh
yeah it makes sense where you know blah
blah blah you know negative energies
backwards in time you get all this weird
stuff happening so you know so i kind of
was in a way misleading the audience by
saying the vacuum but it's more like
space-time itself
got it got it yeah but here's the other
thing to know about the vacuum and
whether or not it's something so we have
the michelson-morley experiment which
allegedly showed that there's no ether
because electromagnetic waves
all mechanical waves that we know of
require some medium to trance to travel
through but light was different so
physicists said there must be some
medium in space because how is it this
wave we call light propagating without a
medium and so michaelson and morley did
the experiment and they found that oh i
don't see any differences but then uh in
these perpendicular directions along the
earth's um orbit and perpendicular to it
you know if you were measuring a
relative speed they would be different
but then you have this person called um
what's his name uh contraction
fitzgerald not fitzgerald what's up
lawrence uh
laura yeah laurence lawrence lawrence
said gerald yeah so lorettz comes along
and says well you know there's another
interpretation of the data and that is
if you know one arm got shorter shorter
by what we call a rinse contraction now
um
so space time itself so so anyway
now we understand in our highest
understanding of knowledge that
everything is fields space is a field
you know the reason why every electron
is identical is because they're not
actual independent entities it's just
like every c note on the piano is
identical because it's a it's a
vibration on a string of a particular
length with a particular you know
density and such right
uh and radius yeah so you know these
electrons are just evidence of this
so-called electron field or lepton field
so you know the universe that we live in
is not the universe we see right and so
when you look at these subatomic
particles they get closer and closer to
that fundamental nature of the universe
right so things start to get weird but
i'll stop there because i'm using up so
much time
okay
all right
all i know is or not
no i mean
you you just said that you were
misleading people like you did in your
class using the word the letter f when
it should be th i think there's a
consistent thing with you with
misleading people because that's how he
rolls he just wants to mislead people
yeah
paul give me we have time for like one
more question paul okay this is uh
sandra okay we have a woman here hi uh
uh
from uh is it possible that we just
should be clear paul you only know that
it's a woman's name
you don't know that it is a woman
that's right i'll i thought that after i
say it that you gotta get accurate just
accuracy in reporting here okay
okay that's right this is uh
okay
sandra whoever you are
uh
is it possible that we found the star
that's 16 billion years old methuselah
is the star i'm referring to it's a
puzzle to me
um
it's a puzzle to us all
exactly yes
so what when you hear that number
there's a second number that is or a
third that is always cited when
scientists talk to each other and hardly
ever cited when the press reports on it
absolutely
and that is the uh cert the error bar
right and there's two types systematic
and statistical errors depending upon
you know how you're creating it
the number um and so my guess is that if
you look at the error bars of the stars
age the error bars of the universe's age
that both are consistent but if you look
at the central value
it appears to be an inconsistency this
has happened before
will happen again
all the science is in the error bar
or
or could the star be lying about its age
just putting it out there
see first you said it was a woman now
you're saying you're lying about the age
this ball i begin to see a trend with
you too man
once we make the monthly show you're
gonna yeah exactly we gotta make the
monthly show the monthly but wait didn't
but then the astronomer howard bond with
his team come up to break bring the
number down to like uh you know 14.8
we're using luminosity oxygen in the
star and rates of nuclear you know
reactions so so here's a point we'll
we'll go out with this with this one
what you want to look at is not the
the number that's the center of the
average that you obtain from the
observations you want to look at the the
uncertainty in that
estimate and every single measurement
ever reported in a scientific journal
when properly reported comes along with
the uncertainty sometimes called the
error bars but error makes you think
they made a mistake but they did right
it's just an uncertainty okay so
i i have no doubt that the the
uncertainties overlap between the age of
the universe and the age of this star
the pro there's a deeper problem here we
actually have two independent ways of
getting the age of the universe
forget the star the universe and those
two numbers are statistically different
from each other where they don't even
enter each other's
error bars
and it's it's a cosmic conundrum right
now
and the two numbers look like they're
close so what are you worried about it's
because the uncertainties have been
beaten down to be so narrow that they
don't overlap anymore
and so either we need new physics or
something with something else deeply
that we don't understand so this canon
does happen and it's happening right now
with the age of the universe
and which of those two methodologies do
you more subscribe to in terms of uh
measuring the age of the universe well
you look you know you you you're looking
at like newton versus maxwell when
einstein was looking at it but you know
it could be they're taken at very
different times in the age of the
universe right one is made using the
cosmic microwave background radiation
highly precise very early in the
universe and the other is using
different types of standardized candles
that are calibrated one off the other
here's what i mean by that the way we
find out distances
astronomically in most cases is by the
first method is parallax so we have a
new satellite hipparcos which is doing
that with super high accuracy within our
galaxy then we find stars of known
luminosity they're in various types the
brightest ones pulsate right these
so-called cepheid variables and then we
have these exploding stars type 1a
supernovae which are calibrated off of
the cepheids so now the question becomes
are cepheus identical in every galaxy
such that we can trust that we know
their brightness to within the same
percentage within every galaxy there's
some evidence that that may not be the
case right
um and so you know if there is a
variation that's i learned the word
autonomous i used to propose to study
this so um
formed were found geologists use that
word so you know is a cepheid period
luminosity relation universal
or is it formed were found right uh and
and then it's the same thing with the
type 1a supernovae do we understand
everything about them and their
environments and intergalactic medium so
there's so much detail and so much to
understand
that the cosmic microwave background
radiation seems like a much cleaner
measurement
but so if you're a betting man that's
where you're gonna put down your money
that's where i would put down my money
um but then there are some things so
here's the problem right well i have to
interject so
what you just said over the last four
minutes there's an entire
chapter in the start talk book
called cosmic queries on that subject
and it's called cosmic tension and it
tells you how you get the distances and
the standard candles and the micro
background and the conflict it's all in
a book cosmic queries inspired by the
fact that we actually have these kinds
of conversations just letting you know
dog got it your book is always number
one in astrophysics and i'm getting
tired of you
it's like you hidden figures the baby
book
look man
i had hey can i say something i have a
book it's how the cow mood all right
it's a it's um it's a top of the charts
of the of the uh i think people should
get both books
between the two books your book keems
book and neil's book starts you know i'm
looking i'm like wait a minute shaq is
getting all the commercials
neal is getting all the book sales like
come on come on give the guy something
give me
you gotta come out with your own cell
phone how about that like
wait paul do you actually have a book
out i didn't know no i don't
okay
i'm actually looking to write a book
about my life story because people no i
thought because if you can write a book
about cows
saying moo
you know the whole story about the cow
jumping over the moon maybe they're
actually saying moon
instead of moon see let me write this
down
let me steal this idea i've already
tweeted it so you make sure it's a
spherical cow spherical cow well you
gotta up them on that guys you gotta
call it quits there this has been great
love this grab bag astrophysics and and
by the way two astrophysicists are
always better than one this is what i
think we have concluded here absolutely
[Laughter]
it's just a lot of astrophysics love
right here just yeah you're feeling it
totally feeling the light group hug
right there
all right so akeem uh good to have you
back and thank you so much
this won't be the last time
or hope not paul been too long uh good
to see you don't be a stranger all right
absolutely great to see you neil
degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]